bajo fuertes medidas de seguridad el
presidente chino xi jinping estuvo en
hong kong para conmemorar un cuarto de
siglo desde la entrega de la ciudad
china por parte del reino unido ante el
creciente control de beijing sobre hong
kong y dijo que la verdadera democracia
de la ciudad comenzó hace 25 años
tras la reunificación con la madre
patria los hongkoneses se convirtieron
en los dueños de su propia ciudad y se
dieron cuenta de que los hongkoneses
deben gestionar algún con word la
verdadera democracia de hong kong
comenzó aquí hanks si tomó juramento al
nuevo jefe del ejecutivo de hong kong el
implacable young lee pro beijing y el
primer ex jefe de seguridad en el cargo
consiguió el puesto en unas elecciones
sin oposición tras las protestas
prodemocráticas de 2019 y 2020 bajo el
mandato de la predecesora del nuevo jefe
del ejecutivo carril am lee fue el
artífice de la draconiana ley de
seguridad nacional proveen jim que puso
fin a las protestas en la ciudad el
viernes dijo que la ley era una parte
integral de la política de un país dos
sistemas de hong kong se han lanzado la
promulgación y aplicación de la ley de
seguridad nacional de hong kong ha
restablecido el orden del caos en la
ciudad
por lo tanto es imperativo que
atesoramos nuestra política durante
mucho tiempo
y es uno de los varios altos
funcionarios de hong kong sancionados
por eeuu por socavar la autonomía y los
derechos democráticos de hong kong ahora
se enfrenta a la difícil tarea de
reestablecer la reputación de hong kong
después de que el centro financiero se
viera debilitado económicamente por la
estrategia china de cero cobit y de que
las duras políticas gubernamentales
impulsarán el mayor descenso de
población de la ciudad en seis décadas